impariamo dal sole non darà malco
minacciano i restanti compiute di mars
inc
[Musica]
beh
è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo io sono qua vj alloggi già i
capelli negli occhi ed oggi siamo in un
nuovo logo ragazzi un casino di cose da
dirvi quindi vedo di non perdere tempo
quindi ragazzi direi di partire come al
solito colla final della settimana che
questa settimana è stata vinta da sul
fiume che ha fatto questo capolavoro
credo che su come sia un nickname perché
altrimenti ad ogni ci guardano dj siamo
scusati ragazzi perché questo blog non è
uscito di sabato come al solito ma è
uscito oggi perché ovviamente sono stato
via tutto il weekend e state tranquilli
ho finito di andarmene in giro era
innanzitutto volevo precisare una cosa
allora all'inizio del weekend
eravamo a 246 mila iscritti comunque
judy di allora cosa ho pensato mentre
rovi ho detto mi farò venire in mente
un'idea per il video dei 250 mila
iscritti cosa non è andata diciamo
proprio così perché io sono tornato
stamattina ho aperto il canale ho detto
vediamo a quanto siamo arrivati
[Musica]
non mi dici
la ragazza è una cosa in più io non ho
mai visto se c'è stata una media di
2mila iscritti al giorno c'è una cosa
succede un ragazzo grazie grazie grazie
perché vi giuro una cosa del genere non
me lo sarei mai aspettata la lotta
negativo e comunque è che sono tornato a
casa ho detto cazzo devo fare lo
speciale perché abbiamo leggermente
superato la soglia di 250 mila quindi è
meglio che mi dia un bel calcio nel culo
e che mi dia una mossa quindi ragazzi lo
avrete prima possibile l'idea mi è
venuta per quanto possa essere pazza ma
mi è venuta e quindi aspettatevi di
tutto con ragazzi a parte questo volevo
dirvi che è la scorsa settimana sono
stato appunto al lucca comics e c'è
stato un momento in cui io veramente
ragazzi volevo un po vederla sa piera
ecc
ho visto pochissimo perché eravate in
troppi comunque a ci teneva a farvi
vedere un paio di cose anche mi avete
veramente che mi hanno regalato al lucca
comics che mi avete regalato questo il
pupazzetto del oneapp morbido sissi mo
che è praticamente diventato non lo
palco tutti i giorni così li in mancanza
di pop e ragazzi ovvero non ho capito
bene perché mi abbiate regalato una
sciabola una mini k non so che cosa
perché c'è scritto in giapponese
comunque mi avete regalato questa
splendida arma che non lo indica che
cosa mi possa servire ma mi piace
tantissimo
ma non che cazzo ci faccio questa roba
fatemi capire
comunque regale news sono finite dire di
passare allo scartato reparti che tanto
so che lo stato aspettando tutti è
questa settimana deciso di scartarne di
nuovo tre visto che ho fatto un po di
ritardo è solo drasticamente enormi e
tanto ragazzi gesto fatto qui che ha
fatto in un modo assurdo io avevo
chiesto ai ragazzi scrivete fa vj su
tocco che mi mandate ma lui mi sa che
l'ha preso un po troppo alla lettera mi
dicono i ragazzi è fantastico non vedo
l'ora di aprirlo questo qua è ancora più
grosso cioè rendetevi conto di chi cazzo
mi state mandando sia stato facciano in
camera da secoli congregazione di
partire dal più piccolo e facilmente
scartabile ringraziando i bio abbiamo
una mini nutella che c'è scritto non
mangiare la nutella e da collezione si
sinceramente non la mangiamo perché ho
paura che me l'avessi avvelenata ma non
importa quella fantastica penna dove c'è
scritto a penna penna fa bj c'è una cosa
quasi topin apa vj ed è assolutamente
originale dopodiché c'è una pagina di
una pagina dello slider man con scritto
simpaticamente folla uffa vj
come se non bastassero le sette che c'è
dietro ed infine ragazzi abbiamo il
videogame di cat mario con tanto di cd
all'interno e ho paura sinceramente di
metterlo credo che non lo fa con che ti
ringrazio moltissimo per il parco e
direi di passare a questi due allora
passiamo prima questo che un po più
piccolo tra che già scritto favi gesù
ogni punto del pacco avvenuti ci sia
qualcosa di decente
abbiamo allora ragazzi abbiamo una
nutella papi già nutella cresta
finalmente quella costituita è
normalmente mi mancava grazie mille
raggiungerò insieme alle altre miliardi
di nutella che c'è una mini fun arte
dello strand airmen fantastica cos'è
store o no non ci credo ma ci voglio
credere
regata e questo no la maglia di scrive
il nova vedrà per questo epico questo è
fottutamente etico in casta maglie 9
dall'essere un attivo di in giro così
ovunque perché esageratamente epica
grazie infinite ma si sa che qualche
prezzo di maglia che ciò è il più bello
che ti piace sta maglia e non è mia il
musical e adesso perché c'è la maglia
più [ __ ] della tua ragazzi è un po
triste perché a lui non ti regalano le
magliette ma la mia cagionata mente più
[ __ ] e direi come ultimo di aprire sto
meglio a patto che non è niente cazzo
sia aprì con cautela
se l'accusa all'interno della scatola si
romperà per sempre ti senti perseguiterà
passiamo a fa mi rispondano ragazzi ho
seriamente paura e che cazzo posso
trovare qui dentro però devo ammettere
che la pizza sul cartone a un balcone di
tutto rispetto chi ha ordinato una pizza
lo slider ragazzi io non ho la più
pallida idea è perché mi abbiate inviato
una pizza lowes lander man però è
fantastica quindi vi ringrazio e capire
ma la reazione che si aspettavano quale
doveva essere scusate
[Musica]
vabbè ragazzi abbiamo finito con i fatti
e quindi direi passare a farvi risponde
ma vi rispondo è fin che ne pensi del
nuovo sistema dei commenti di youtube
svaligiate vogliono leggere allora
ragazzi questo è un argomento che volevo
dire nelle news ma mi sono dimenticato
vabbè comunque praticamente ragazzi in
questi giorni che sono stato qui al mio
ritorno a casa ho aperto youtube e ho
visto che finalmente sia stato un nuovo
grandissimo aggiornamento porca [ __ ]
tennis zerbino non farti trattare come
il tuo cognome fa risponde poi puoi
girare la telecamera verso sinistra
facendoci vedere i fatti
e certo che sì ma risponde farine
prossimo blog ci fai una clip di cat
mario mentre imita miley cyrus in
wrecking ball a chiederla
[Musica]
conca ragazzi non ho tantissimo tempo
quindi dato il rientro devo stringere
abbastanza scusatemi se questo blog è
così al prossimo cercherò di rispondere
a più domande comunque ci tenevo a
precisare v che ormai sono tornato
quindi tranquilli non ci saranno più
weekend nel quale tentò di arras fare
cercando di caricare più video possibili
per coprire il buco ragazzi tranquilli
perché lo avessi davanti ci sono sempre
quindi ragazzi non preoccupatevi perché
di media si ritorna con un video al
giorno tranquillissimi e spero che vi
piaccia lo speciale che sta per uscire
perché cercherò di farlo uscire prima
possibile da questo sabato non ne sono
sicuro ma ragazzi questo sabato se tutto
va bene faccia uscire lo speciale
250.000 iscritti quindi preparatevi come
si deve perché sarà epico ma anche
ragazzi concludo qui il blog
se vi do è piaciuto come al solito show
ad un commento mi piace anche la pagina
di facebook e come non invidio tratta
nella descrizione essere per iscritti
iscritte vendi ci rivediamo il prossimo
video bella ragazza